we get in close you all know the drill
intercept the convoy watch out for cable
edit there's this kid he's in trouble
mover guy pump the hate breaks Thanos
Halon cable get to him but I can't do
this alone
back up we're gonna form a super duper
[ __ ] group it's time to get back on
LinkedIn meets bed and love my name is
chatter stark Domino I'm lucky luck
isn't a superpower it's not very
cinematic yes it is let's meet in the
middle and say no it is [ __ ] It's
Showtime don't call it a comeback
[ __ ] hero you're just a clown dressed
up as a sex toy so dark you sure you're
not from the DC Universe
bring it on one night Willie
[Music]
whoo yeah your bullets they're really
fast last but not least Peter
any powered want to tell us about you no
I don't have one I just saw the ad
you're in hey everybody it's Charlie so
we got a breakdown in this new Deadpool
trailer if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos pump the hate break stano's
you're so dark you must be from the DC
universe that second line is right out
of the movie you know who knows if the
Thanos line makes it into the final cut
of the movie but I was waiting for them
to take a more legit shot at infinity
war because they're being released so
close to each other just as League is a
really easy target but if he didn't spot
it they spent the first movie making fun
of Wolverine Origins they also included
another Wolverine Origins moment in this
trailer cable just starts firing his gun
at that convoy and he starts slicing his
blades around is the exact same scene
from the beginning of Wolverine Origins
when he slices the blade really slowly
bring it on one-eyed Willy
whoo yeah your bullets they're really
fast the backup joke to that is the fact
that Deadpool during Wolverine Origins
blocks all those bullets with his swords
in Deadpool doesn't block any of cable's
boss like literally every single bullet
he fires out of his gun goes through
Deadpool but because he can heal it
doesn't matter that he gets hit with
bullets that's why he says wow your
bullets are really fast because he
misses all the bullet blocks with his
swords so just more shots at the
ridiculousness of Wolverine Origins and
then obviously there's the Goonies joke
because Josh Brolin was in Goonies he
also tells a lot of funny stories from
the set of that movie saying really dumb
stuff to Steven Spielberg and Steven
Spielberg getting really short with them
just like come on kid we're making a
movie here let's keep going they did say
that they would be taking shots at
pretty much every big sequel so not just
Justice League and the DC Universe not
just Avengers infinity war in those
Marvel movies all kinds of sequels so
let's just go through this shot by a
shot because there actually is some
legit footage of them showing off X for
showing off cables superpowers his
telekinesis shatter star in this funny
Peter regular guy is featured
prominently like he jumps out the guy
with the moustache I thought it was
gonna be Colossus without his
superpowers and it was gonna be some
joke about that but turns out it's just
like some random guy I just saw the ad
you're in but turns out it's not just
like a funny joke for this moment he's
on the back of this plane then jumps out
with them when they go to save the kid
and it does really seem like it's
Russell Collins I did a video earlier
this week I didn't have to like cut out
part of this because it was like a TV
spot that I guess Fox didn't want out
early because it has some footage this
also in this trailer even though it's
not quite the same video anybody who's
ever been on YouTube trying to do
trailer videos or anything like that
knows exactly what it's like dealing
with Studios sometimes we don't get that
many scenes with Bill scars guards
character but it really does seem like
he's zeitgeist because of that yellow
mouth covering and he doesn't even have
dialogue during the trailer so I'm
wondering if they're gonna kill him off
during the movie because they are
forming x-force but I don't know that
every single member of this group will
make it to the x-force movie look they
might cycle the roster a little bit but
just because bill skarsgård was penny
wise in the it movie in the it movie was
huge don't assume that he makes it to
the x-force movie so I think most of
these
people will make it 2x4 suck shatter
star is obviously a really big deal he's
a huge character total badass obviously
cable domino Colossus negasonic teenage
warhead I think we've all collectively
decided that this new character is Serge
even though they haven't confirmed it
yet but for the most part they just want
to show you more of the actual story
them just recruiting everyone and then
focusing more on the dynamic between
Deadpool and cable so like they don't
even have that much footage with
Julianne Denison's character so I'm
guessing that maybe they retooled the
movie just a little bit to focus more on
the cable character but I do like the
way that he talks to Domino luck isn't a
superpower I beg to differ
why don't we meet in the middle and say
that it's not the Panda joke is
obviously just about the way the
Domino's face looks in the comics they
tuned it a little bit for this movie
like it's not quite as start but in the
comics it really does look like a panda
eye but it's also just a way to show you
how she is super lucky literally her
ability is giving off a probability
field that gives her a good luck but
it's not straight-up luck it's actually
just like a small field around her that
affects probability in anybody that's in
proximity to her so if she wanted to
affect Deadpool's probability and give
him good luck - she would need to be
really close to him or touching him but
at the same time like you see this
person in the DMC car that she jumps
into she can give someone else bad luck
while she's giving herself good luck -
so they're mostly playing it for comedy
in the trailer but we'll see how crazy
they get with her ability because it's
pretty useful but it's not crazy
Omega level powerful look at this poster
in the background - this is for a comic
book because it says number 52 on the
bottom corner here but I'm wondering if
this is a Batman V Superman joke because
of this giant subtitle because it says
Presley versus casein and the hidden
crystal of doom
so it almost feels like they're trying
to take a shot at Indiana Jones and the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull and Batman
V Superman at the same time but just
like I said they're taking shots at
every big sequel so it would be too
surprised if they take a shot at Indy
for most of you probably know who's
shatter star is but if you don't know
who Lewis tan is he was actually one of
the legit badasses from Iron Fist
what-you-see-is-what-you-get he has
really crazy looking double swords they
actually look really badass so it'll be
fun to see him in action we haven't
really seen a lot with him you
mostly just Deadpool with his swords but
some of the other background Easter eggs
in here are just a little too small to
see so once we get like the HD master of
the film we can just comb through the
background let me know if you spot any
on the back walls here but like any time
they cover a room in this much just
random debris
there's tons of Easter eggs in it they
also use this montage to tell you about
bedlam character I think we'd figured
that out after the last trailer after we
saw Terry Crews for the first time but
bedlam just can generate bioelectric
fields and put people to sleep or to
stun them for a little while there were
a lot of people when I posted that video
earlier this week that saw Colossus
punching this metal dome here and
thought that it might be the juggernaut
I don't think that's the case I think
they're just trying to tell you that
it's on the back of this truck here but
there's just like all kinds of craziness
happening in this moment there's a shot
where you see Colossus get shot into
that news van but the way they cut it is
kind of misleading I think it's meant to
be the fire fist kid Julianne Denison's
character shooting him with his blast
and like when you see negasonic teenage
warhead raise her fists up I think that
that's probably him trying to shoot her
too and her just blocking the fire with
her power they also release a picture of
Deadpool in that x-force jersey with the
other members right before what looks
like this scene like they walk up and
trying to talk him down before he goes
crazy and just shoots fireballs at all
of them so if you guys didn't know Josh
Brolin confirm he's doing at least four
Deadpool x-force movies and that's
between those two franchises technically
x-force is gonna be a Deadpool sequel
but because Josh Brolin is like okay for
film art for cable starting with
Deadpool to x-force is gonna be the
second movie they'll probably be a third
Deadpool movie and then an x-force
sequel small update on that Fox Disney
deal to Fox people themselves said that
they expect the deal to finish by the
end of the summer 2019 but what will
happen is is they just released a game
of Thrones Season a parody trailer I'll
do a video for that next then there's
New Avengers infinity war that should be
out later tonight leave all your
requests in the comments below click
here for brand-new infinity war and
click here for that other Deadpool video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]